Nantz come yes come Curtis I'm never
going to be able to say the movie title
right sorry
I've ruined the everybody hey Internet
welcome to another rousing rendition of
eg at the movies where we get you ready
for what's hitting the box office this
weekend I'm ash Carlson and did you like
that intro fabulous intro I'm speechless
hahaha hi I'm John boon and we have a
twofer for you this week we have King
Arthur legend of the sword and we have
smashed let's kick things off in
alphabetic order because why not look
worried about King Arthur :
legend of the sword the colon is how you
know this is going to be a franchise so
this one is about King Arthur the
legendary King Arthur stories and the
knights of the round table starring
Charlie Hunnam and Jude Law as our
villain directed by Guy Ritchie and yeah
it's about King Arthur the sword of
Excalibur which is the legend of the
sword bit and then that's the sword that
they pull out of the stone in case
you're mixing up your medieval sword and
the knights of the round table so yeah
who knows how many they're going to be
but we did ask Charlie Hunnam about this
and he is still in sight
enjoy the accents I signed on for three
I would do as many as guy wanted to do
yeah because I know that guy has real
integrity and he would just he would
only be telling these stories if you
have story to tell one of the big
problems with the Arthurian legend for
film and historically what's always been
difficult is is this sprawling Odyssey
ask tale that just goes on and on
wonderful colorful characters come in
but try to distill that down to a one
film size increment has always been the
trick every really tricky so a guy does
is just tell the first chapter so
there's so much I mean there's the real
meat of the story left to tell you know
got into it asked I mean I whenever you
Lancelot Merlyn all of that so there's
there's there's easily two more very
very exciting films to make and who
knows maybe even more but that's as you
know to the audience to decide we we
have the passion and the will to do it
but it'll just be whether people turn up
and enjoy this film and want to see
yeah could be as many as three movies at
least with Charlie Hunnam don't die yeah
give me that Merlin movie is so what did
you think of the movie I liked what I
could understand I did not understand a
lot I told you this when we walked out
of the theater it felt like the sequel
to a King Arthur movie I had not seen I
think the first I would say even our I
was like what until he pulls the sword
out of the stone right I don't know what
is happening and I think even if you
know the legend of King Arthur and you
was like the ancien movie and read all
the books or whatever I would still
really lost but there was fun parts in
the confusion there's I mean you only
have to wait 15 minutes to see Charlie
Hunnam shirtless and from the point we
beat him I believe we see an shirtless
three times in the first 10 minute he
has two full shirtless scenes before he
speaks four words and I can't decide how
I feel about the action sequences
because I did feel like I was watching
like the end of final boss level on
Tekken 7 oh yeah xx a B pow pow pow do
that combo move KO um what I did think
was interesting is there is one
character in this movie who I swear to
God is the dark and gritty live-action
version of her Celeste from The Little
Mermaid I think we both means over to
each other at the same time we were like
is that some Ursula and then off of that
when Charlie Hunnam is parkouring his
way through the city he has which he
does obviously at the Guy Ritchie movie
you're like oh I know what the Guy
Ritchie Aladdin is going to be because
Guy Ritchie if you forget is directing
these live-action Disney Aladdin is
there truth to Will Smith playing the
genie this is the rumor and it would be
pretty amazing um I have to tell you I
love it if that's the case and
everything I understand that seems to be
going swimmingly
he's certainly my number one choice and
I don't know we'll come together so this
isn't a movie we're talking about this
week but we'll talk about it a million
years in the future a million years
material Aladdin every hiding out but
moving on to
on our movie coming out this weekend
smash smash that's how you have to say
it next yeah all right I don't know as
you certainly already know snatched
snatched stars Goldie Hawn it starts Amy
Schumer it's directed by Jonathan Levine
who did 50/50 he did warm bodies that
zombie I loved warm body I do and he has
to love it I was going to say zombie
rom-com I wasn't a bunch of just like
such a great and the night before a few
years ago with Seth Rogen where they're
all doing drugs on Christmas classic a
core topic what else do you doing um and
it's written by Katie Dippold who you
would know from the heat she did
ghostbusters
ghostbusters that I love don't at me the
biggest thing about snatched isn't any
of that it's that this is Goldie Hawn
first movie in 15 years
where's she staying where though because
she had Amy Schumer is probably Goldie
Hawn uber fan number one and so I wanted
to know what her top five the movie the
Goldie Hawn movies we had to binge
before snatch and so Cameron Mathison
after for me and here's what she said I
mean overboard like of course I love
seems like whole time
I gotta have like a swing last vote
because you know because I'll love first
was club and then house sitter and
Private Benjamin it's like a you know
it's too hard because they changed being
that you are a super Goldie can I do not
yeah I need to say that like your dog I
know but I cannot we us together we the
world all of you what is your favorite
well we helmet do you think we have the
same one shoot at same time it's the
same yeah okay three two one
dark on now
[Laughter]
don't try to change me in any way First
Wives Club is great and I spoke to
Jonathan Levine who a first of all he
said his favorite Goldie Hawn movie is
Private Benjamin but I mentioned there's
a moment in the movie where Goldie Hawn
dances I won't tell you when and I said
that was kind of like a First Wives Club
throwback and he told me that after they
shot that he went up and hugged Goldie
and she said thank you for letting me do
sweet I know you're like number one
snatch fan number one saps dad I love me
a dumb comedy like I love Oprah
over-the-top your favorite word's
bonkers bonkers bonkers Muriel I love
vacation which people hated I loved why
hand which people like some people
dragged whatever I'm not above a dumb
crazy over-the-top comedy and I liked
snatch a lot if you liked Amy Schumer in
trainwreck you'll like Amy Schumer in
snacks right it's the same kind of
hilariously monstrous woman child who
did she the trainwreck yes when I saw it
in the screening room everybody was
laughing out loud and then whoever went
and gave it a bad review like you
laughed in the theater like don't even
know I did laughs and Amy is so good at
what she does Goldie is so good at what
she does and they're so good together
there came a time when I look at her and
I thought she could be my daughter and
that's when I had this urge to hold her
so two very different but also competing
movies so if you had to pick one which
one you're gonna go see this is a little
cheating because we both know each other
I say emphasis if you want to do about
three yeah okay three two one me yeah
I forgot where things match like that so
you want people to see snatch because
you genuinely loved snatch I genuinely
think and I also think it's like a good
movie to go see in a crowd of people
work because the laughter is very
contagious appreciator it's also a great
movie to watch on an airplane
it's definitely an airplane really yeah
but I chose this where Amy approached
Goldy for the movie anyway so yeah there
you go everything's coming for Darryl I
have a little more info on that I have a
Q&A going up with Jonathan Levine on eg
online later this week check it out I
talked about how he got Goldy I talked
about the tapeworm scene which you will
be all you want to talk about after you
see this movie I also talked to him and
why I chose smash if I also talked to
him about if you would do a sequel and
he said he said if he did a sequel he
would kind of maybe not want to see him
get snatched again and that's the movie
I wanted to see I wanted to see Goldie
Hawn just at home raising these awful
children with laughs why also pitched
him directing how are you leaving us to
go be a screen yeah I am I am will
scripts already written let me finish
I'm sorry but I am leaving to join a
development hi but I said he directs ami
stars Goldie stars again as her mom with
Jennifer Lawrence in that script that
Amy and Jennifer Road where did that
script go somebody where genuinely I
think I caught him a little off-guard he
was like that would be something I would
love to do anyway anyway go see snatch
Josie snatched and King Arthur yeah you
would love if you have contrarian takes
on King Arthur's and people say donut at
us at us find us on Twitter at us tell
us what you love besides Ursula come
back next week where we will be talking
about should we say hungry three two one
alien you company yeah feeling covenant
came back Nexus
you